going on board
[Music]
Philip Schofield hits out at his critics
but is called delusional by one
ex-colleague as this morning's Staff
address claims of a toxic working
environment
caught in the crossfire a special report
on the conflict in Sudan and those
fleeing across the border
for all of these people here have come
across to look for safety
risking their lives to race we report
from the Isle of Man TT as efforts are
made to make the competition safer
[Applause]
thus Painting the Town orange luton's
players and fans come together to
celebrate promotion to the Premier
League
and we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages in our press
preview from 10 30.
[Music]
a very good evening over the last decade
more than 20 000 people have died or
disappeared attempting the world's most
dangerous migrant Crossing and yet the
numbers trying to make the journey over
the Mediterranean from North Africa to
Europe are rocketing
Sky News has witnessed the rescue of 600
people from an overcrowded fishing boat
after it was abandoned by its captain
well already this year more than a
thousand people have died attempting to
cross the Mediterranean one of the key
routes known as the central
Mediterranean route is from Algeria
Tunisia Libya and Egypt and these people
make their way towards Italy or Malta
well last month alone more than 14
000 people traveled across the med via
this route and so far this year the
figure sits at 42
165. this is a
292 percent increase on the same period
last year our Europe correspondent Adam
Parsons and his team saw the latest
Rescue first hand
we're on the bridge of the Geo Barons a
rescue ship patrolling the Mediterranean
on the lookout for migrant vessels in
distress
yeah the Moon is there already
and they've seen one a dot in the
distance but we're heading towards it
let's get ready
we're joining the rescue crews as they
prepare to Launch
we can set up we are just getting ready
to go on the ribs as we approach this
fishing boat which is reported to have
hundreds of people on it and is in
distress the Italian Coast Guard are
there they've lost the Geo Barons to
carry out the rescue
the water we speed away using two rescue
boats they're known as ribs
the nearer we get the more people we can
see
but it's only when we get right next to
the boat that you can work out help
every inch of space has been taken
and there are hundreds more people
crammed out of sight
in the underbelly of the boat
the challenge is to get them all off to
safety so we've been Distributing life
jackets to all the people on board this
boat now the first person is coming on
board
it's not a general process there's no
time for introductions or nice it is
this is about saving lives
many on board are dehydrated ill and
injured
and among them babies and young children
two ribs alternate Journeys back to the
Geo Barons with 30 or 40 passengers each
time
this old fishing boat set off from the
Libyan Port of tre Brook it could
probably have carried 30 or 40 people in
safety
instead there were 606 people who were
on board and they were all brought off
alive
people off the rescue boats and onto the
Geo Barons is hard work the boats have
to be maneuvered precisely
and then the passengers transferred
sometimes with particular care
when they arrive they're all given food
water and new clothes
it must be a bewildering experience many
of these people expect it to die
we meet handy and Assad they painted
desperate picture little food no water
and suddenly abandoned by their own
captain
in the middle of the sea wouldn't always
north east south
or just lost the geobearance is run by
the charity medicine San Frontier this
the biggest rescue the ships ever
carried out
around most of Europe the number of
migrants is falling but in the
Mediterranean it's up 300 this year so
as we head back to port in Italy the Geo
Barons isn't guaranteed a particularly
warm welcome the Italian government says
that ships like this are a magnet that
they are effectively giant taxis for
economic migrants
it's an accusation the charity denies
if yes people why they're leaving their
countries while they're putting all
their life and their families in one bag
facing borders facing a different
situation facing even that because
everyone knows that this route is quite
deadly you will easily understand that
there is no way to promote migration
already this year at least a thousand
migrants have died in these Waters and
the summer approaches this route will
just get busier
or we can speak to Adam now who's still
at Sea in the Mediterranean good evening
to you Adam extraordinary and harrowing
scenes witnessed by you and your team do
you know what comes next for these
people
yeah well on a very practical level what
uh happens next is that tomorrow morning
there's both of your Barons will dock in
the Italian uh town of Bari and the
migrants on board will be disembarked
now we don't know how long that process
will take this is the main office for
medicine in San Francisco on board and
this is where they will be coordinating
their side of the deal they simply don't
know that it might take a few hours it
might take the entire day there is of
course a tension on ongoing tension
between the people on site on this boat
charity that they work for uh and the
officials who will be greeting us and I
don't think there's only way to
sugarcoat this the people who are on
this boat these 600 migrants I think
quite a lot of them have a Rosy view
that they are going to be welcome to
Europe that I've had a number of people
saying that they really want to
assimilate themselves they want to be
part of Europe I I don't think many of
them realize that they may well face
actually a rather Frosty perception that
there are plenty in Italy and across the
continent who resent this migration and
who worry about this growing number of
people who are coming across the
Mediterranean and yet there are others
here who think that this is their chance
that they thought they were going to die
on this boat a miserable lonely death
they almost think they've been reborn
and believed that what they've Left
Behind was awful and that whatever is in
front of them however unwelcome may be
however many obstacles may be in their
path will be a better life
go inside Adam thank you
now the Fallout from Philip schofield's
ITV exit is growing with tensions
visible both on and off screen today
Monday's edition of this morning began
with its presenters addressing claims of
a toxic working culture while Scofield
took to social media to hit out at his
critics a move that provoked criticism
from one former colleague who described
him as delusional Rachel venables has
more
who would you like to hear from today it
was an attempt to show that it was
business as usual but Dermot O'Leary and
Alison Hammond did have one message for
viewers just from both of us and the
whole team here the crew the guys
downstairs uh we love making the show
for all of you yeah we really need to
and that's exactly what we're going to
do even guests were Keen to show that
the wholesome image of this morning
wasn't tarnished by recent Scandal we
are very happy to be here can I say that
as well but just 40 minutes before the
program aired Phillip Schofield had
dropped this explosive statement on
Instagram I hope you've noticed that
it's the same handful of people with a
grudge against me or the show who seemed
to have the loudest voice this morning
is the best show to work on with the
best people in all the years I worked
there there was no toxicity
fields and other this morning presenters
are denying these allegations of a toxic
culture on the show but rumors are
swirling about how much ITV bosses knew
of his relationship with a younger male
colleague and whether it was hushed up
ITV say they investigated the
allegations but they're both parties
denied any involvement but now former
friends and colleagues are turning on
each other
former this morning co-host Eamonn
Holmes tweeted Scofield has just put out
a delusional statement like Holly he
puts it on Insta stories so if it goes
wrong there's no record after 24 hours
I'm reluctant to give the liar any more
publicity but believe me pip if you are
looking for a fight you have picked on
the wrong person not pattern baldness is
95 of hair loss it comes after the
program's former doctor said he raised
concerns about bullying and
discrimination on the show but claims he
was then managed out for whistleblowing
ITV shares have gone down the question
now is whether the damage to the brand
will last if there are more mistakes if
they're more debris then that's going to
fly up in the face and it's going to
cause them a lot of problems of the
brand but they're hanging tough and I
think that that you know there are there
are lots of occasions they weathered the
qgate storm arguably
um when news came out of how many other
journalists jumped the queue
um they didn't lose advertisers they
didn't lose audiences so they're used to
this Holly Willoughby is expected to
return to co-host this morning next week
but the future of the program remains
uncertain
and our correspondent Rachel venables
joins me now from outside television
Center in West London where this morning
is filmed and a lot of speculation
Rachel about the future of the show
absolutely and you have to bear in mind
that the appeal of this morning has
always been in its syrupy sweet
family-friendly image you know the site
of Phil and Holly to seemingly and I
think it was true for many years best
friends on the sofa together in the
studio here at television Center in West
London that was how they sold the
program and that's what the audiences
loved but that has been really badly
damaged with all of these revelations in
the last few days whether the damage is
permanent whether it's fatal of course
we'll have to wait and see bosses here
will certainly hope that that's not the
case but they've been dealing with a
firestorm over the last few weeks from
of course that really clear-cut moment
when Phillip Schofield put out that
statement on Friday and then over the
weekend and into today you've had people
speaking out about what's supposedly
allegedly been described as a toxic
culture including former presenter
Eamonn Holmes contributors as well
talking about as you heard that report
being managed out after whistleblowing
this is what is now facing this beloved
program we're waiting of course as I
mentioned for Holly Willoughby to return
to the show so real questions there as
to who will co-present with her if she
does return next week will she
acknowledge it and as I've already
mentioned in the medium to long term if
there aren't any more allegations or if
there are can the show survive we'll
have to wait and see
okay Rachel thanks very much
plans for the Metropolitan Police to
stop attending 999 calls involving
mental health incidents have caused
alarm among Healthcare and charity
bosses the forces commissioner believes
the move will free up officers from
incidents they're not trained to deal
with but there are fears it could put
vulnerable people at an increased risk a
crime correspondent Martin brunt reports
in his first weeks as the new
commissioner Sir Mark Rowley singled out
dealing with mental health issues as a
major distraction for his officers
too many hours spent waiting with
patients in hospital emergency centers
not enough time said the commissioner
preventing and fighting crime
retired met police officer Chris Hobbs
blamed Public Health spending cuts
mental health hospitals have closed or
been reduced in size the whole Mental
Health Service is under stress so the
police have had to pick up the slack and
basically they've said well we can't we
can't do this anymore
the commissioner says from the end of
August his officers will stop answering
emergency calls involving mental health
patients unless life is at risk
in a letter to Health and Social care
providers Sir Mark Rowley wrote every
day that we permit the status quo to
remain we are collectively failing
patients and are not setting up officers
to succeed We are failing them first by
sending police officers not medical
professionals to those in Mental Health
crisis
he said officers were spending more than
14 hours handing patients over to
medical staff taking up ten thousand
hours of Officer time each month last
month he said only 30 percent of 999
calls were actually crime related
I think it is worrying for for patients
and service users and mental health to
think that in London at the end of
August there is no other number to call
at the moment there is only 999 that
relatives can call when someone's in
that crisis and that's not going to
change between now and the 30th 30th of
August Scotland Yard has called for an
urgent meeting with health Chiefs
the commissioner is confident in his
threat to stop responding to all but
life-threatening mental health crises
because he knows it's worked elsewhere
pilot scheming humberside brought police
health and charity staff together it
could be adopted nationally eventually
but the Met says it can't wait for that
Martin brunt Sky News at New Scotland
Yard
uganda's president has approved one of
the world's toughest
anti-lgbtq laws increasing the maximum
punishment to the death penalty the move
has provoked International condemnation
the UK government says it's appalled by
the new law while U.S President Joe
Biden said it was a tragic violation of
Human Rights
ethnic serbs in Northern Kosovo have
clashed with police after attempting to
storm public buildings demonstrations
have been ongoing since Friday in a
dispute over local elections held last
month the nato-led kafur peacekeeping
force said that 25 of its troops were
injured in the clashes Serbia has put
its military on high alert and sent more
troops to the border with Kosovo
to Ukraine now where Russian ballistic
missiles targeted the capital Kiev in a
rare daytime attack this morning
many residents in Kiev were forced to
seek shelter underground our
International correspondent Alex Rossi
reports
it is almost a daily occurrence as
Moscow steps up its aerial bombardment
of Ukrainian towns and cities
this time the strike was during daylight
hours it was the middle of the morning
when a barrage of missiles rained down
on the capital
these images show terrified children
running through the streets looking for
cover
all of the Rockets were shot down but
Falling fragments caused a number of
casualties
a piece of debris fell near my house I
thought I had dropped something then I
saw on our house group chat that
something fell near to our house I went
out to look and there was a fragment of
a rocket lying there
and for the frightened residence it
means hunkering down Underground when
the air raid siren sounds
I heard two or three explosions and then
I heard five or seven more explosions
that's when I realized something
terrible was happening I read the
telegram channels and thought it'd be
best to go to the subway after all
there have been at least 15 attacks this
month alone mostly at night officials
claim Russia is changing its tactics to
try to evade Ukraine's air defense
systems they know that we have improved
our capacity a lot and right now they're
trying different tactics to uh have us
um fire all our missiles to have us
um show where the locations of them air
defense systems are and of course to
take down the morale of the people the
intensity of Russia's raids is
increasing ahead of Ukraine's
anticipated counter-offensive
people here are expecting more attacks
in the coming days
Alex Rossi Sky News
with the conflict in Sudan still
simmering the violence of darfur's
ethnic conflict condemned by the world
in 2003 has returned
more than a million people have been
displaced internally by the recent
conflict in Sudan while more than 330
000 have fled to five neighboring
countries Egypt Chad the Central African
Republic South Sudan and Ethiopia
Well Chad has taken in 90 000 refugees
the second highest number of those five
countries a correspondent usra El begier
begins this next report from Eastern
Chad where fighting can be seen across
the border in Sudan in the town of Mr a
one of Westar Ford's largest border
towns mestere is burning
and as the chadian military approach
they can do nothing but watch
as we were approaching it looked like
Mist over the valley but as we got
closer you can see that as plumes of
smoke Rising above Villages that have
been scorched by ethnic conflict
we drive further east and find its
latest victims
seeking shelter under every other tree
still in a State of Shock
people are dying shama says the war is
still raging
I ask her if they'll come seeking
treatment but she says they're still
trapped inside
this is the crossing point a dried
riverbed they're safe in Chad now but
can still see and hear the signs of
wreckage
this Valley is officially that foreign
just across the way you can hear gunfire
is still ringing out of the villages
where fighting continues and all of
these people here have come across to
look for safety from what they see is a
continued targeted assault
you can hear it now
she says that's the sound of rifles the
very rifles that they've fled to come
here
is your family there I ask the chorus
replies yes they're in there being
killed
some stay on the border to Bear Witness
the wounded start coming in
[Music]
just three years old even Bilal wasn't
spared from the bullets
and his older sister is forced to watch
their mother is still trapped but many
are making their way out
[Music]
this man and his son have escaped the
regional capital of elginena where a
massacre has been reported
I asked him to tell me what's happening
there he says daily death
the survivors keep streaming in
pained by bullet wounds and a familiar
Grim reality
Sky News Eastern chant
now since its Inauguration in 1907 the
Isle of Man TT race has seen 266
fatalities it's considered to be one of
the most dangerous motorcycle events on
the planet but competitors are still
queuing up for this month's race despite
the inherent risks Rob Harris reports
everywhere there's danger
nowhere's more dangerous in Motorsport
and yet they keep coming to compete I'm
not forced to be here I want to be here
it's an obvious risk risks Riders have
been taken for 116 years at the Isle of
Man TT with the course death toll
reaching 266 after six more fatalities
in 2022 but no one here especially not
the Island's fastest ever racer was to
contemplate Banning the world's oldest
motorcycle race after the tranches of
last year did you have any trepidation
about coming back this year to compete
not at all no I mean a lot of people
think we're just crazy or idiots you
take your brain out put your helmet on
it's very very much the opposite effect
so you've really got to use your brain
and you've got to take the risk when you
once take the risk or if it's necessary
but life is short as it is you know I
would rather
go away doing something like this and I
would crossing the road and getting run
over by a bus
but this is where no one wants to end up
a rider has been injured on the first
morning of racing
and they arrive at hospital as we're
meeting the events medical Chief the
circuit's 37 miles long approximately
we're about 20 miles from some of the
patients who are having the helicopters
uh is absolutely essential it gets the
doctor and the paramedic there literally
within minutes so a vital piece of our
response speeds can reach 200 miles an
hour
in racing compared to jumping out of a
plane without a parachute padding on
Lamppost offers little protection
it's around here a father and son Roger
and Bradley stopped and crashed in a
sidecar race and died last year it's
racing around these residential streets
that makes the Isle of Man TT so
thrilling so compelling yet so dangerous
it's so perilous that world championship
status was lost in 1932. yet new safety
measures organizers and insists should
reduce the risk of more Riders dying
here it is inherently dangerous or um
we're rating in high performance
motorcycles on a closed Public Road and
those dangers are are obvious
um
there is a kind of constant battle to to
manage the um those risks that are
avoidable and sit around this to try and
make it as safe as possible to win you
must risk dying without the rewards of
other sports grief goes with the glory
Rob Harris Sky News on the Isle of Man
football now and Luton Town's players
and fans have come together to celebrate
the club's promotion to the Premier
League thousands of people came out for
a Civic parade and our correspondent
Melena veselinovich was among the crowds
they started the season as underdogs but
they made it to the top of their game
[Applause]
players getting a hero's homecoming for
reaching the top flight of English
football for the first time in more than
30 years voice is gone as you can as you
can see and in here but yeah I mean 48
Hours has been a whirlwind
still quite hasn't sunk in yet
and I mean yeah we're just here to
celebrate this wonderful day with with
the town this is a very rare moment you
don't get many moments like this in your
career so I think all we've got to do
now is enjoy it soak every bit of it up
[Music]
and the town was soaking it up to the
fans painting it orange and coming out
in force for a team which they say made
history
[Music]
feel proud they feel that their team was
the underdog where they came out on top
and they have now come out to say their
thanks to them
so many here the win was truly a dream
come true
[Music]
and it's that positive momentum that the
town now wants to build on hoping that
the team's success on the pitch will
mean better fortunes for everyone it's
jobs a lot of opportunities for our
young people I'm a teacher and I want
them to have a bright future where they
can call looting their home if it goes
anywhere they want they come back to
Luton and stay here and you think this
one might help that as well absolutely
because instead of looking at all these
other big cities Luton will be their
home where they can build a future for
themselves
a future that will see luton's players
facing off with the best of them
after three decades finally back in the
big time
villanovic Sky News
well that was Sky News at 10 coming up
we'll be taking a first look at
tomorrow's papers in the Press preview
including this story on the front of the
Metro about the latest Chris criticism
of Philip Schofield by Eamonn Holmes
their headline the gloves are off
and tonight we're joined by political
correspondent at the financial times
Jasmine Cameron cheleschi and former
conservative special advisor Anita
boating there they are standing by see
you after this short break
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome back this is Sky News in just a
moment the Press preview a first look at
what's on the front pages as they arrive
but first our top stories
Sky News has witnessed how 600 people
had to be rescued from the world's most
dangerous migrant Crossing in a
Mediterranean
Schofield has defended this morning as
it came under Fire with claims of
toxicity amid Fury over his affair with
a younger colleague
Health Chiefs have expressed concerns
over plans for the metropolitan police
officers not to attend emergency calls
if they're linked to mental health
incidents
thank you
hello there you're watching the Press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive and in the
next half an hour we'll see what's
making the headlines with political
correspondent at the financial times
Jasmine Cameron chileshi and former
conservative special advisor Anita
boating there they are standing by but
first let's see what's on some of those
front pages the gloves are off that's
how the Metro describes the latest
exchanges between former presenters
Phillip Schofield and Eamonn Holmes over
the behind the scenes culture at top ITV
show this morning
Boris Johnson's WhatsApp account and
what it might reveal to the covid-19
inquiries top story for the Times which
says a legal Wrangle is looming over
getting the messages released
the mail leads with what it calls Fury
at labor leader sakistama over a one and
a half million pound donation to the
party from a top funder of the just stop
oil movement and demands it should be
returned
the mirror speaks to the mother of a
ten-year-old boy killed by a dangerous
dog who is backing the papers campaign
for government action to stop more such
cases
the eye reveals that people could be
asked to recycle less waste to cut down
on the number of non-recyclable items
finding their way into the recycling
system and having to be rejected
the express says that High Street banks
are under increasing pressure to offer
better rates to Savers after a witch
report found rates at the moment are
often meager and unjustifiable
the financial times leads with news that
labor is planning to Force Major
landowners to sell off plots cheaply if
it gets into power in an effort to cut
the cost of building new homes
and that is also the top story on the
front of tomorrow's Guardian
while the star tells us that experts
think we've been drinking our beer the
wrong way and that it needs to have more
of a head on it because it's better for
your Bell
there you go and a reminder that by
scanning the QR code you'll see ons
you'll see on screen during this program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's papers while you watch us
let's speak now to the political
correspondence at the financial times
Jasmine Cameron cheleschi and former
conservative special advisor Anita
boating who are here with us to review
the papers this evening great to have
you both with us thanks so much
um Anita I'll kick off with you first if
I may because we're going to be talking
about the front page of the Metro their
headline leading on this ongoing storm
at ITV the headline the gloves are off
what's this article saying
yes so this updates
um the world on the latest Ferrari
between
um presenters and former presenters now
of ITV so this is um Phillip Schofield
opting on his Instagram page to
effectively
um dismiss the claims of toxicity behind
the scenes at itvs this morning
um to which the former presenter Eamonn
Holmes who left the program in 2021
according to the paper has then
responded on Twitter saying you don't
want to pick a fight with me pip
um it's all quite public now the The Rao
um between the former presenters and
obviously the
um bad feeling ever since um Philip slow
Scofield was it appears to um be it was
sacked as a result of what has been
reported to be
um conduct with OR carry on with an
employee who was there at quite a young
age so
um it's definitely something that has
itb's this morning in the front pages
over the past few days and this is a
sign that it perhaps might not be
abating anytime soon yeah certainly the
storm rumbles on and and the future of
the show in doubt uh very much so now
Jasmine to you Nexus let's talk about
the front page of the Guardian because
uh just so the viewers are aware you've
asked not to comment tonight on uh this
morning given that you are moving to ITV
later this summer so let's talk about
the front page of the Guardian labor to
let councils buy land cheaply to tackle
the housing crisis this story on two of
the front pages today
yeah so it's a really interesting story
and it looks at the fact that labor
officials are discussing plans to give
local authorities powers to buy up land
cheaply and then develop it and of
course we know that housing is set to be
one of the key issues going into the
next general election be that what's
happening in the rental market or what's
happening with mortgages or trying to
get more first-time buyers on the ladder
so it's a very interesting set of
proposals that the party are discussing
and of course labor officials know that
actually if they put forward a strong
electoral offer particularly to those
aged between 21 and 40. those
individuals who typically would be
getting on the housing ladder would be
starting families and would
traditionally be voting um becoming more
conservative with age but statistics
show that that's not happening and so
labor officials feel like if they can
tap into that core voter base actually
they've got a strong offer to put to the
public and it will be quite interesting
to see how cchq how the leveling up
Department engage with these brief
proposals and perhaps they'll try to
offer some sort of counter alternative
going closest the election
yeah and Anita is there anything you'd
like to add to this kissed armor is is
under Fire for his promise to make it
easier to build on the Green Belt as
well
yeah and he's got this sort of broader
ambition to have 70 of people
um in the UK to be homeowners and it's
it's very clear that labor doesn't
really have a clear idea about how
they're going to achieve this so um it's
interesting that we've got this
announcement now about compulsory
purchase orders and I won't bore your
viewers by trying to explain exactly how
this works effectively um local councils
can acquire land in quite limited
circumstances and there's an indication
here from this story that they're going
to allow local councils to go much
further than that but I don't see here a
clear indication of how this would make
a demonstrable difference
um to the broader housing ecosystem in
particular around house building
um because often councils acquire
property basically for development
purposes and not for necessarily
straight for building houses so again I
think it's a lot of ideas sort of
slightly throwing things at the wall and
seeing what things would make a
difference because actually increasing
house buildings substantially is quite a
significant Challenge and I think it's
interesting that labor thinks this is
winning ground and it's certainly
cleared the public want to see more
house building but achieving that it's
actually quite complicated it's not
clear that there is a comprehensive plan
for delivering that
okay and just on uh political and policy
ideas Jasmine this story inside uh
tomorrow's Metro about uh Rishi sunak's
uh plans to perhaps put put a price cap
on on the cost of essential Goods to
help with the cost of living crisis uh
it certainly sounds according to this
article that there are some industry
figures who who doubt whether it will
work
yeah so these ideas were briefed to the
weekend papers I think they first
emerged in the Sunday Telegraph this
idea that ministers were discussing
perhaps a voluntary cap on essential
items now we all know anyone that's gone
to a supermarket we've seen the price of
basic as like milk eggs bread cheese
Dairy all of this has gone up and it
really is impacting particularly
low-income families and so the
government has briefed out these
proposals but there really has been a
bit of a backlash on all sides that
you've had conservative MPS and
ministers who were very instinctively
against what they feel is excessive
State Intervention basically arguing
that this isn't really conservative
proposal and then you have
um leading business figures arguing that
actually this isn't really going to make
much of a difference and it just feels a
little bit like posturing so it seems as
though the government is scrambling to
look as though it's got some effective
proposals to bring down inflation now if
we remember bringing down inflation is
one of cenac's five pledges to the
public that he wants to halve and play
Asian by the end of the year so
obviously there's a little bit of a Mad
scramble at the top of government as to
as to how they go around doing that you
know how they create a perception that
actually the government is on top of
this issue and is doing all it can and
exhausting all channels to really look
as though it's on the side of the voters
on the side of consumers to get some of
those prices down yeah it's interesting
isn't it this idea uh Anita what do you
make of of this you know mad scramble at
the top of the government as Jasmine put
it there what do you think is going on
as a former conservative advisor
I wouldn't quite call it a mad scramble
but I do think that the figures out um
earlier in the week about inflation and
particularly about the levels of core
inflation that we're now seeing in our
economy is deeply worrying and I think a
sincere concern in number 10 and
likewise in HMT about the level of
inflation that now seems to be
um slightly bedding its way in and what
that means for people because inflation
does you know sort of destroy the
economy for a lot of people in terms of
how how much poorer it can make people
and the government doesn't have a huge
number of levers that it can use and to
support that and we know that the
supermarkets are very much you know
wanting to do their best for consumers
so I think it makes sense to me that the
government would want to talk to those
retailers and say look what more can we
do to make sure that across-core areas
and it's particularly
um when it's purchasing items that
people who are poor old see and feel
that inflationary hit much higher what
can we do to keep those prices is down
at a point where food inflation is at a
30-year High
um so I think it makes sense for the
government to be having those
conversations it doesn't look like the
government is looking at regulating and
it's much more about a voluntary
agreement but if it does come up in some
fashion I think that would really help
some of the poorest people who are
really struggling with food prices yeah
it's interesting isn't it let's talk
about the front page of tomorrow's mail
Jasmine before we go to a short break uh
Fury at storm is one and a half million
pounds from just stop oil donor their
headline uh tomorrow morning saying that
kirstama is under Fire over donations to
labor from a key funder to just stop oil
yeah and I do think we will probably see
more and more of these stories heading
into the general election as there's a
lot more scrutiny over where parties are
getting their money from who's donating
what the stories behind these figures
and of course um just stop oil is the
Environmental Group that has been
embroiled in some level of controversy
in the past few months over some of the
tactics that it's used to to get its
messaging across and so in that light
particularly there are individuals who
arguing that stormers shouldn't have
accepted the money or now should return
the money as some sort of gesture I'd be
skeptical as to whether that would
actually take place but I think as I say
there'll be more and more of these
stories and more of a bit of a rifling
through you know the party's expenses
and and figuring out who's funding some
of these political parties and how much
we can read into that
yeah Anita your your thoughts on this
story certainly just stop oil
um has divided opinion in the way
they've they've carried out some of
their protests
really is we've seen the announcement um
recently from kirst armor about stopping
a multi oil drink and Drilling and
that's obviously about whether the UK
can remain energy secure so there's
clear indication here I think that
um just stop oil or whether it's via
this connection from the donor or
whatever is is impacting the labor party
policy and that's where I think there
are some genuine concerns because the UK
isn't a yes at a stage where it can only
use renewable energy for instance and
therefore you're in a situation where
either you know the UK is producing its
own oil and gas or the UK is buying on
the global market and we've seen what's
happened to Global oil and gas prices
recently so I think there is a a broad
and more serious concern about the
energy Security in the future if
geostorm's policy comes to fruition but
I think an interesting as yeah yeah
sorry I don't know why I Had a Brain
fade in your name there
um I think that as we get closer to the
election there'll be more scrutiny about
the motivations behind some of these big
policies that will be coming from both
political parties yeah don't worry
neither brain freeze is a real thing
isn't it we'll leave you both to rest
your brains momentarily uh standby
thanks very much and do stay with us
because coming up we'll be looking ahead
to more of tomorrow's front pages
including this on the front of the
Guardian Alarm over met vow to quit
mental health role more in a minute in a
minute after this short break
foreign
[Music]
I'm Becky Johnston a Sky News
correspondent part of the team based
here in the Midlands
allegations of exploitation in
leicester's clothing factories aren't
new in fact it's been an Open Secret in
this city for years
[Music]
made for people who want Clarity in an
uncertain world
two more and more stabbings and
essentially I think it's more younger
children there's a team we're not really
surprised by anything these days
so there's reports of a male who just
have repeatedly in the leg
here in the diverse industrial heart of
England we hear from people who have
real stories to tell
parents are going to complain like this
and schools better get ready for it
these protests are being organized
primarily by people who aren't parents
at the school
so some patients aren't going to survive
this we have to be prepared that
patients will die from from this illness
staff here are currently identifying
wards that could be turned into in areas
where patients with covid-19 could be
isolated
the river seven is still rising and
people here in Ironbridge have been told
it could go up by another meter before
it starts to go back down
it's going to be a long slow process of
putting it back together
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the Press
preview and with me is the political
correspondent at the financial times
Jasmine Cameron chileshi and former
conservative special advisor Anita
boteng good to have you back with us uh
let's speak to you first Jasmine if I
may the front page of the Guardian
covering uh this story that we've been
covering today about the Metropolitan
Police and the decision by the
commissioner not to respond to mental
health calls unless there's a threat to
life your thoughts on this
yes there's been a bit of a um you know
there's a bit of been a bit of unease in
response to his um his calls so
obviously this comes at a time where
there's a lot of pressure on the
metropolitan police at the moment to get
to grips with
um you know just basic crimes things
like burglary things like fraud also we
know the Met has been embroiled in lots
of um concern over it's handling of
misogyny within its rants particularly
after the murder of Sarah everard so
what we're really seeing is
um you know a senior figure from the Met
police arguing that actually the police
for a long time have also been you know
they've been effectively a form of
Social Services as well as crime
production and prevention and he's
arguing that the force really needs to
get back to base Basics and just focus
on its main remit now obviously lots of
campaigners and and people that work in
in the NHS have warned that actually
this creates a gap where if the police
are stepping back from there from this
um role that they've been filling
actually do the health services and do
the local authorities have the resources
to give people got support when they are
having a mental health crisis and
they're looking for somewhere to turn
and I think it speaks to the fact that
many of our like um Public Services many
of our local services in particular are
really feeling a level of strength
either for funding or general resources
and I think this this lesson really kind
of gets to the heart of the really tough
decisions that a lot of local
organizations are having to make on a
day-to-day basis about how they allocate
their resources yeah certainly there
does seem to be a real problem with
provision uh an Anita and and certainly
we were discussing this earlier on Sky
News and one viewer messaged me to say
you know there are crisis teams
available for people who who know who to
call and not everyone does but even if
you do call that crisis number not
always you know it isn't always the case
that your call gets answered
yes and I think that there is a kind of
broader issue the Met police of Embassy
had a tumultuous
um past few years but this is a problem
that is impacting lots of police
services and the guardian that
originally
um kind of broke the story about this
met police
um letter had some some studies um in
Humber police um which I believe which
showed that them having implemented this
scheme where health professionals came
to those mental health calls rather than
police if there weren't this sort of
imminent threat did make a difference in
terms of freeing up some police resource
so I think that I would want to be led
by the evidence here and if there is
some indication that actually this means
that things are dealt with at a more
appropriate level and you have police
able to deal with other situations for
which they might be better trained I
think that makes sense and I think in
the in the situation where there is not
a lot of resource to go around thinking
about the evidence and allowing that to
be the decider about who responds to
these cases seems to make sense to me
let's move on to a story inside the
Metro Now Jasmine this daytime
attack on Ukraine's Capital Kiev today
certainly it's very rare for the capital
to be attacked during daylight hours and
and it's been an absolutely terrifying
event for civilians there
yeah and so the Metro is reporting that
the head of the Ukraine's Military
Intelligence has effectively issued a
stock warning to President Putin saying
that there will be some sort of Revenge
attack in retaliation for what has been
perceived to be a dramatic escalation of
of
um you know of the conflict so far as
you say to have an attack of this nature
in daytime to Signal a slight change in
tactics I think it's just another
reminder that you know this war really
doesn't show many signs of of ending I
think perhaps at the very beginning of
the conflict there was Hope on the
Russian end that perhaps this would be
an easy conflict then to win but
obviously we know that Ukraine um helped
with um alongside Western allies have
put up Fierce resistance and it does
seem as though both sides are
effectively digging in both sides are
ramping up in terms of the tactics and
weapon you Weaponry used and so and
unfortunately it's the civilians of
Ukraine that are caught up in the middle
of this and end up having to live the
real very real consequences of this
conflict yeah absolutely
and Anita front page of the eye
so-called wish cycling government plans
to crack down on it we actually talked
about this a lot at home that if you
throw something in the recycling you
can't recycle it's actually worse
because then potentially the whole the
whole load of rubbish gets gets thrown
into waste
absolutely and I think that often
councils do their best in terms of
trying to educate people about what goes
in and what goes out but I think there
is a lot more work to do especially
around the condition of things and
whether they should be put in at that
stake because the amount it costs to
kind of make things recyclable in terms
of cleanliness Etc that's all part of
the equation and I think that households
want to do their bits
um to make sure that they can recycle so
it's all worth being everyone grabbing
the front page of the metro and giving
it a good read
absolutely Anita Jasmine great stuff
we'll see you again next hour thanks
very much indeed
let's have a look at the weather now
shall we
warm memories wherever you go
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways
this week looks mostly dry with plenty
of sunshine but northern and Eastern
coastal areas will be cooler and
cloudier at times with some wind off the
sea too there'll be a mainly fine if
chilly start tomorrow with a ground
Frost possible in a few areas but
Central and Eastern England and many
Northern Scottish coasts will be rather
dull
the morning will bring plenty of
sunshine to most with Cloud over
Northeast Scotland and Central England
slowly burning off Inland but Eastern
England will remain largely overcast
the weather sponsored by Qatar Airways